please welcome my good friend
[Applause]
that was a street style challenge i just
want everyone to know i just didn't talk
to stop talking about streets by the way
i totally picked up what you were
putting down okay great as a person who
has seen every episode of every single
project runway in its history i knew
exactly what you were saying okay great
i think it's impressive too for a show
to be on 19 seasons yeah and continue to
get better
elevate not ever lose its essence we're
elevating this season
i judge them harshly but it's great but
you know
what i do love is listening to someone
who i know they know what they're
talking about so
your mentorship for me on this show is
pivotal because i'm just like
you know i'm really in it you know i'm
coming at them you know not in a
judgment way to be fun and funny i
really i'm serious like i'm like no i
make clothes every day when i leave set
i go to my office and i dress michelle
obama or the first lady dr jill biden i
know something about dressing fabulous
women i'm gonna even
talk about billy porter that's a man
that i i will never forget that moment
in fashion i didn't know that a man
could ever wear something like that i
had never seen it in my mind by the way
i have this book this is a beautiful
reissue of your gorgeous coffee table
but can i ask why you're so inspired by
tulle because i think it's like a
pavlovian thing for women i'm inspired
by it because my sister growing up was a
ballet dancer so i was around these
fairy-like creatures and and that's what
i loved i love this transformation you
know you see a dancer and they're in
warm-ups and sweats and it's like kind
of ugly and then they turn into like the
sugar plum fairy and i always thought
that was so beautiful so that's kind of
what i like to do with my clothes which
is why
any red carpet or any moment is like a
true transformation for me well i love
fantasy yeah and you know i love to mix
it in with reality and halloween is
coming up which is my very favorite
holiday in the world the best okay well
i'm excited to see your take on
halloween i can't actually think of
anyone better
yeah than to teach us some halloween
tips and tricks this is a costume a very
um diy
at home you can do this yourself
and we're going to start with what are
we fighting with oh it's a gumball
machine oh my gosh okay that sounds
elaborate yeah it does it's not um
and it's a gumball machine and i really
think it's one of those things that you
could like stick your mom in the corner
so like this is for the kids at home and
just like throw pom-poms on her and um
and she's a gumball machine okay let's
see i want to see come on out natalie
[Music]
[Applause]
mom's in the corner and she's got a
white t-shirt and all the kids just
throw their gumballs on with glue and
it's safe and she has those jeans
obviously because everyone has those and
they're candy they're candy colored and
it's candy colored and it's a gumball
machine for like ten dollars okay lila
what do you think of this outfit are you
thumbs up
he's down fine
maybe we get maybe like like an eight
like eight out of ten
[Music]
by the way what do you think of your
kitty outfit i love it i'm always the
same thing every year for halloween so
i'm so happy i have something new this
year okay what are you every year um an
old lady every year
wow
why what is the psychology because my
mom was like vampira every year i think
it's just like i love the golden girls
oh so okay that's why
i didn't know where this was going
golden girls very happy yeah love it
here is my dear friend fashion designer
extraordinaire christian siriano
and if you want to see his designs in
person he has an exhibit at the savannah
college of design museum of art and our
next diy costume is oh french toast come
on out tasha
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so if you're at home and everybody
has a striped blouse and a red scarf
hopefully and if you don't you need it
and um so you need a beret which is
you know easy um and then you get some
cardstock you cut out whatever your
shape of french toast could be it could
be mickey mouse french it could be
whatever and i think that a pack of
post-its would be cute for the butter
and who doesn't like a pad of butter
yeah exactly lyla
thoughts okay oh
[Applause]
yes are giving me like audrey hepburn
and funny faith like i feel like i'm
transported to paris how do you feel in
your outfit i'm shocked at how easy it
was to put this together and i never
thought i could be french toast i like
waffles a little better
well we can work on that next day okay
well your french toast
thank you tasha i think you look
stunning head to toe and natalie look at
these
[Applause]
um
my my girl's um aunt jill cardman is
going to be cruella and my daughters are
going to be her dalmatians but they're
like also kittens and like hybrids what
should i dress as for halloween oh my
gosh i don't know
madonna which madonna no and we could
paul madonna let's do it we'll call her
after this and we'll say can we borrow
something from the archives this is it
we're doing it oh my god i'll call it
right now okay let's do it oh my gosh
okay
okay christian siriano i love you so
much when's our next date what are we
doing tomorrow see you i'll see you
halloween as madonna okay perfect i love
it christian siriana tune into project
runway
[Applause]
later this fall
[Music]
you